si vabbè allora gialle su vitale
sempre che dovrete portare alla fine chi
vince tra me e lui stesso e attualità
perché abbiamo preparato l'uomo a 20
guardino questa volta non in questo
brano the groms tutte per le nuove
decorateli che avete visto nel mio video
unboxing vegas temi corrivi per i sette
mesi e prezzi ha deciso di farli
diventare unico mini maxi fondo
ottima comunque la spinosissima mente
[Musica]
drone americano in pratica vi abbiamo
sette guanti comunque pasto presenti le
bellissime decorazioni dovete poi dopo
stesso via sappia vedere colpito di
shopping slide stilemi peste tutte bene
nel dettaglio sono qatar che comunque
non è diverso da una volta non c'è la
frolla bianca è la sola trasparente ma
in ogni quanto strane 36 fuori con la
trasparente in alcuni dipinti in altri
di meno li vediamo quale sono mi piace
di più è questa se resterò sta benissimo
fa tutti gli piace perché era un piano
delle caratteristiche bene quello che mi
piace di meno e il numero 6
perché ci sono le decorazioni berti e
sicuramente riuscirà
ammettiamo dimesso il loro stesso era
sono sicura
5 perché il sangue
se palline bianche questa pallina
trasparente colorate di più la frutta e
spero di un abbraccio allora
praticamente come funzionano e non
andiamo a sedere quanto ma andiamo a
girare la ruota come l'altra volta al
numero che capita andiamo a prendere il
guanto e metterlo nella ciotola poi alla
fine andiamo ad attivare lo slime e
bonomi desiderate chi vince subito il
punto lui batterla bellezza del lo slime
come sempre c'è anche il cambio slime
quindi non è detto che il sistema non è
bellissimo fino alla fine poi va bene mi
capita scambio mi è capitato anche
insomma penso che avete capito ad occhi
chiusi
scegli tu soprattutto sceglie l'altro i
visi dei bronzi prendete le patatine i
pop corn mettetevi con iniziamo subito
questo challenge preparatevi a fare il
voto per me l'ha visto il video dovete
votare i piani ben raccomando il
commento mi dispiace lido ma questa
volta vinto l'italia
frantini numero 4 che volete
mi capita è capitato in quanto se lette
è noto al numero 4 atp finito ad aprirlo
via v come a me piace non sa portare a
riguardo i korn e così dentro mi
raccomando stare attenta nostra
dopotutto basta tagliare un po così
l'effetto bellisismo bellissimo come
sempre da milita anche male le contesto
anche polizia
allora guardate quella te come sente ok
schiaccia un po piccata telematico per
sempre sappiamo infatti già benissimo
baratro e celeste rosa poi così da etro
stufa di dover rivedere quindi metterà
poi vice di lippi
ciao 5 che non sembrano utilizzato no io
ho usato il 45 occhio qualcuno sia le
palline quel piccola stabilissimo sai
brutture timorati dentro anche mai perso
però quel momento del mister che sembra
non so perché mi fa pensare un po una
cosa porta vuota latte che stesse del
modello niente persona 5 già bellissimo
dall'amico messo un sacco di frutta là
dentro
accantonando paura ha desistito state
sentite camera fa paura ma un sacco di
cazzate non sentiamo interpolare quindi
ora tutto questo e prato che porta
proprio paura comunque stava dicendo
mentre vitale cerca di togliere le cose
dal traguardo
lasciate un bel nike non sono per questo
challenge per vederne altri ma
soprattutto perché ci ho messo tipo 1 ml
più parenti guanti sembra facile così
con un tacco di che mortali quindi mi
raccomando be like e di quanti quello di
anita ora pure i glitter ma voglio
mettere con questa bella bella tutta la
frutta del ducato lucca quindi agli atti
volti ok tocca a me ne dobbiamo
guardarli sembrava branca aveva iniziato
bene comunque mi è capitato dotto quindi
non lo fu prendere niente a loro tocca
ai tg rai
[Musica]
da questo c'è il glitter delle stelline
mi piace questo già troppe cose
incasinato questi monumenti bello che ho
trovato io no perché mi colorare
zucchine dentro vedere bellissimo perché
il numero 6 portafortuna gli effetti ti
conviene di più efficaci certa cultura
non certo il numero uno è bellissimo e
un mancamento bellissimo ma soprattutto
dentro stupendo quello che lo schalke i
kit sono la metro è infatti lo sta
scolando un pochettino anche tenuto in
piazza è una maniera dedicassero l'unica
questa volta di colore viola
il maniero scambi che guardate un po
come te la faccio a campare stupido ma
perché vanno per viola pacchetto came
via
non intendo non cipro non è possibile
spiega se vi prometto allora io so voi
nei commenti mi avete scritto nica se
come si è capito che mi avete scritto
siccome questo non mettere cose debito
si mai un lamento apposta per vedere se
veramente succede sempre così succede
sempre così non sei tu che oggi il verde
il verde chiama tempo
tanti rinnovi non ci di rivendite i tory
ma non per interposta nas in compagnia
di 6 microsoft tornato più vuota ma si
sa perché come ti sei da voi c'è un bel
tempo finita l'estate nomadi in terapia
ma non lo accetterò mai che guida da te
allora vi faccio vedere questo
bellissimo quanto dai almeno 6 glik
rossi ha le conchiglie e verdi e
so che persona mattine arancioni un
altro colore che non mi piace tantissimo
[Musica]
ecco fatto per averle conchigliette
dovrebbero fare lo slime super crunchy
con un sacco di suoni quindi ma lei
punti smr tu magari per bellezza ma per
essere dico io perché per votare alle
imprese
r morisco che amiamo organizzatore su un
piede dentro o che vivono a vedere con
chi ne che cadevano juan per un rumore
dell'ambiente ha obbligato video è ok
non è male devo dire farà perché temiamo
klein marino picco perché e celeste
mosso con le conchiglie e le conchiglie
aperte che soldati che con conchiglie a
kakà ok ce l'hanno fatta come tutte le
conchiglie che poi questa ragione frate
che bello
lo ha deciso che se rimane mio lo
chiamerò a e mostrano un celeste come
l'acqua e questo le conchiglie del 31 e
beckett cielo stellato a misano sarei
per dirmi che non c'entra niente con ciò
che anche ricordato quando lui ha
chiamato jazz cielo scaduto
ecco nasca tutto cielo scaduto com'era
che per tre moto stellato ma che como
non torna a casa 0 0
ciao ciao domani che non lo meno lecce
dai rom è possibile che mi hanno mandata
proprio a mezza passato sia di viaggio
tra pubblico allora è capitata 6 e
l'altro quindi lui deve essere quanto
per me fai vedere quanti allora abbiamo
il numerone che sono la pallina
poi abbiamo il numero 2 che con la
trasparenza il glitter durati quasi il
bronzo e per tante piccole cosette qui
che hanno
sono mister e poi avevamo il numero 7
che sono le conchiglie rosa con un po di
glitter rosa quindi se devo scegliere io
scelto le spalline questi non diventa
più crunchy diventa meno gradi c
prego di 20 minuti anzi con le palline
semmai in vetta più craxi charter armato
da dove studenti
adesso capita scambio così capitate bene
non mi ha sempre fatto contenuto tedesco
eccole tra l'altro quel per sono le
palline grandi non quelle piccoline che
uso in genere ha detto non c'è più un
effetto oceano il mio flyin concesso
loro giano inquinato dalla plastica
veroli e sicuramente farà più suoni del
tuo corso in 31 ma niente che passoni
che core da qui la bellissima
l'aspetto dei bellissimi oceano male
pallino inquinato
[Musica]
[Risate]
si era quello che volevi pubblica le
faccine dentro
miley e qui avuta qui altre cose e poi
esplode tra un bellissimo sfidiamo
questo è il bello tre faccine che cari
ok mi manca dormono sì dove
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciò che non vi preoccupate bene è
normale che capitano spagnolo sono
segreti ma non quanto siete pronti
sceglie l'altro sintomi pubblicato
proprio in un ottimo quindi questo
nell'ultimo round e poi andiamo ad
attivarlo è purtroppo non e capirà
toscani ma forse rimarrà new york è
bello vediamo chi lo sa guardate queste
sono glitter rosa e twitter viola e
conchiglie grotta quindi se non era per
le palline sarebbe rimasto super marino
questo live che bello come il sen
molto bello
cast è un po di paura ma interessante
che consente dei comunicati sport non
sapevo che devo carmine hildebrand
troppo il miracolo ecco la stoccata il
tuo diventato bruttissima così il panino
di euro non si capisce niente
un po mon herzog rock inglese il mio
prendere carica
andiamo ad attivarli come quando questo
diventa glia molto molto carino terremo
creare il mio dei bellissimi colori più
alle pallini che vive se tu e le
conchiglie quindi forse parassoni più
crearci forze prendiamo dobbiamo mettere
la porta dell'inferno
purtroppo
è trasformata da una challenge super
allegra a un inquietante falsi perché il
mio coricato malizia che si sistemi a
fallire
sicuramente male ripari
ora cambiamo il quadrature con il cazzo
modo delle medie scusate lo volete la
pioggia sperano di via troppo fastidiosa
e piazze ok ragazzi
ecco il mio allora abbiamo chiuso la
finestra così non si sente troppo e il
rumore della pioggia
allora primo vi faccio vedere cometa
aspetto allora vedete le conchigliette
di cui vi parlavo prima ci sono sia
verdi che rosa poi ci sono le palline
per sono di buono e cd e fare i colori
di glitter
penso che quando questo studio diventerà
trasparente sarà fighissimo c'è nel
senso quando si tolgono tutte le bolle
lo sapete insomma ora mi faccia sentire
studi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che i ragazzi pensare al mio fianco
potete sentire non sacco di rumori
prince ma anche altobello due video il
tumore è stato detto fino adesso temo
che i figli
io non me questa è la mia picchierà
della frentana questa mia pizzella lei è
bello veramente super super bello
colorato bello trasparente opaco come
questa cosa nera tipo sembra pepe di
zombie l'inter comunque ho detto sembra
per poi guardare un appello lungo così
bello morbido si allunga facilmente di
ello altro che a quella cosa dite netta
mio cliente lunga facilmente l'uomo
regolarli veramente
per favore togliti sto finito io la
presentazione allora guardate quanto è
bello bellissimo sapere se questo non è
10 moto10 proprio per la presentazione
bellissima adesso sentiamo un po di
rumore scoppiato kant lo diciamo anche
adulti del poc i miei offrendo niente e
cellule rumore
stupendo è stupendo votate mi raccomando
sentito che bei rumori bellissimo ora
con questo adesso che diventa cli car
e meraviglioso beh allora facciamoli che
delle stelle c'è quell'ammasso lido
monnezza che genova quando è quello c
aromatica mio fragoroso non fragolina
qui non so se lo vedete fragoroso lui
bello guarda lucia gruppo
si guarda
certo che troppo troppo bellissimo con
le stelline di smile tutti belli e
colorati e fantastico allora ragazzi
come sempre
notate nei commenti chi ha vinto questa
challenge date molte do na li si per
appendere foto donna10 imperfezioni smr
fargli sapere quali altre cialente
vorreste vedere sul canale scrivetemi
pure tutto nei commenti che altre salme
non volete vedere contro i dianesi e ora
mi lascia un po a 4 capelli e su cui
potete cliccare anche vedere i prossimi
video da notare tra i video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao